tournoi des cinq nations la france
s'enfonce a là encore été battu cette
fois au parc des princes par
l'angleterre les sens en baisse le mois
prochain ce mec inconditionnel de toute
façon ce serait une baisse légère mais
quand même toujours apprendre espagne en
marge du procès des putschistes un appel
du roi alors 10 m messieurs bonsoir le
coq n'a pas mangé la rose loin de là les
rugbymen français ont été battus bien
battus sur leur propre terrain au parc
des princes battu par un 15 angleterre
nettement meilleure au terme d'un match
d'ailleurs assez plaisant le score est
sans appel 27 15
jamais la france n'a paru en mesure de
gagner le match et on se pose maintenant
des questions très sérieuses sur son
comportement pour la suite du tournoi
mais avant la réflexion de roger couderc
et le commentaire du sélectionneur les i
match les images du match parlant les
français son mollet par 6 à 0
ils attaquent limite les attaques
viennent regarder blanco ce qu'il va
faire
c'est incroyable il va marquer non il
est bloqué un maître ligne de but il est
pressé
france 2 quelques fautes de mer et une
fois de jugement comme ceux de ses
fantastiques qui n'a pas été marqué là
c'est rodriguez avait plaqué la fête
leur partir sur la droite
lancé par martinez réservoir velasquez
encore thierry perrier alors que deux
hommes étaient démarqués à sa gauche et
qui sont tous déçus seul franck et pablo
tellement déçu qu'ils voient pas que les
années montferrand council ou et beauté
des 22 mètres alors que les procès sont
pas encore revenus issus des mêmes
groupes doivent déposer leur mentent pas
ils veulent plaqué sans ballon ses
premiers jouets ou d'ordre même comme si
son bol d'eire toute récente et materis
entre les poteaux
vous allez voir on essaie sans fil ou un
essai vraiment construit un bel essai
jésus pas très d'accord avec la livrée
en famille avant d'avoir gardé sa le
froid qui part comme une flèche qui fixe
et qui est là pardon année c'est le cas
de m
la connaît
transformer le produit l'assistance à
regarder au ralenti son vol à faire il
jongle avec la balle si grosse 21 ans
résiste percée de safran
c'est france et ça fixe et ce alors ça
madame et perrier oui et perrier va
marquer regardez bien pendant d'abord
c'est très intéressant pour un essai
marqué par la phrase pardo bon ça c'est
la mi temps
la trame est à on est mené par 12 à 6
c'est pendant c'est pas terrible mais
hélas ils vont marquer un autre essai
c'est la fin d'ailleurs on a sauté sont
empressés de kent et écouter des
réflexions au micro de jean monnet est
déjà complète expliqué jeudi matin les
matches qui restent à jouer
ce sont fatigants quant au classement
final du tournoi et peut-être que nous
permettrons de deux équipes qui
s'étaient inscrits aujourd'hui mais
la victoire n'était pas au bout alors
qu'il faut remettre en question tout ce
que nous voulons de faire ou vous
continuez à cette voie car quand même
s'il ya pas mal de négatif éducatif on
peut encore citer les trop nombreuses
fautes que nous commettons il ya quand
même s'il est positif puisque parfois
l'équipe de france a bien joué bon il
faut dire la vérité quand même manger
vos petits ils vont pas très bien
investissez la vérité je rédige les
français n'ont pas fait une mauvaise
portée du tout mais les anglais ont eu
de coup de chance
par avis n'aurait eu cette valse moi qui
l'inventé il a amené comme une balle de
football c'était incroyable qui entoure
le ballon est ovale il va droit toi que
je n'en avais que tout droit jean tout
vraiment tout balader au parc des
princes est quand même plus grave que la
fois dernière mais le show et de
rivières on en penser
finalement une bonne journée tout le
monde sauf moi d'ailleurs mais en fait
un film on était content il y avait eu
du jeu les anglais ont marqué un essai
je vous lis heureux il ya un arbitre qui
avait décidé une pénalité pour la france
à 18,15 c'est très important pour
compresser le match bascule et
d'ailleurs y avait dix minutes à jouer
salefranque rose laval s'apprête à tirer
et l'autre juge de touche qui le juge de
touche qui s'appelait monsieur jeunes
burnett appel
mais serait il habite devenait paris si
l'on appliquait pas pour elle et pour
les pour les autres ce nouveau règlement
ce abonde il me suit rêve alors c'est
pas vous seule fois qu'elle est tirée
une pénalité à 40 mètres face aux
poteaux ça ça passait mais c'est l'autre
en rose en vie alors il ya pas l arbitre
n tv chile mais non à vrai dire ce qu'il
faut faire pour gagner maintenant est ce
qu on a remplacé les sauteurs on est
loin d'être joué il faut remplacer
quelques joueurs mais pas toute l'équipe
je refais l'accord est crooks donc
l'équipe d'alf on a une bonne partie
elle m'a fait me fait vibrer c'est nous
les avons mieux joué ont pris quelques
balles en touche ils ont été dominants
bene une mêlée qui faisait 820 kg ch les
hommes je n'avais jamais vu ça en fait
un trio de moyenne au sol il faut mieux
les nourrir et puis et puis ça ira quoi
manger on connaît depuis tout à l'heure
le futur vainqueur du tournoi en irlande
j'ai gagné pour la troisième fois et
cette fois ci à à la zone euro devrait
voir 21 12 21 points inscrits par un
seul homme oui aux lycans belles choses
qu'on va voir
du coup plus consoeur avoir marre
ossements on va avoir quelques années
parler et se changera un peu
alors oui comme bell bien sûr c'est pas
celui des couches et c'est celui qui va
botter
et en plus je premiers pas de joie de
reims ont tout pillé dans son coup de
pied
il ya là comme ça du second ghana
maintien police qui le record en record
absolu pour un seul homme donc ce n'est
pas pas du tout mal et qu'on préfère
années ces mesures et comment marchent
les français que que ça pourrait être un
peu comme ça bon en tout cas ces
irlandais qui ont d'ores et déjà gagné
le tournoi on les reverra à paris dans
un mois puisque ce sera le bienvenu en
l'honneur des du quinze de france le
reverra et j'engage tous les paris
d'accord une longue habitude des salles
de rédaction et des dépêches nous a
conduit ce matin à une grande prudence
au vu des premières informations d'une
possible baisse de l'essence c'est oui
une baisse et non pas une rose s'il y
avait de quoi s'interroger bien sûr nos
voisins belges ou italiens sont
coutumiers du fait mais cela n'était
jamais arrivé en france
alors pourquoi et surtout pourquoi
florence grave
pourquoi eh bien parce que le pétrole
brut coûte moins cher et ceci pour deux
raisons d'abord les pays consommateurs
on fait des économies d'énergie les pays
comme les etats unis la grande bretagne
l'allemagne et la france en ont acheté
en 1995 à 20% de moins de pétrole
ensuite les pays producteurs et bien ils
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre pour limiter
leur production
alors c'est la loi de l'offre et de la
demande plus de pétrole moins
d'acheteurs résultat les prix baissent
officiellement il ne baisse pas mais
dans la pratique il y à des rabais des
ristournes alors ça revient à peu près
au même résultat au marché libre de
rotterdam qui est une sorte de baromètre
il baisse actuellement d'un quart de
dollars par baril et par jour bon mais
si les prix du pétrole baissent batterie
qui n'était pas évident que les prix de
l'essence suivent
par exemple il aurait pu baisser ces
dernières années quand le dollar a
baissé
or ça ne s'est pas fait parce que le
gouvernement barre avait choisi de
constituer avec la différence une espèce
de cagnotte qui devait servir à éponger
les hauts et les bas des matelas voilà
lorsque le gouvernement actuel est en
train serait en train de mettre au point
ce serait une nouvelle méthode de
fixation du prix de l'essence basée sur
les prix de rotterdam et sur les prix
européens
alors le premier pourrait être cette
baisse pour le mois prochain bien on
parle de 10 centimes pour le super un
peu plus pour l'ordinaire mais c'est
vraiment des suppositions des réunions
ministérielles vont avoir lieu
là dessus la semaine prochaine ce serait
donc pour bientôt pour bientôt dire si
je regarde le calendrier on va tomber
normalement il ya des élections
cantonales c'est vrai certaines manquons
pas de faire remarquer mais il faut dire
que la france n'est pas la seule les
automobilistes italiens et belges ont
déjà touché leur baisse le 5 février
dernier
voilà si l'essence se met à baisser il
va falloir réviser tous les plans
d'économie d'énergie et dans ce domaine
les bureaux d'études de six cuillères
carbure beaucoup en ce moment ça sic un
véhicule expérimental vient d'être mise
au point il utilisera deux modes de
propulsion l'électricité et gazole un
petit bus qui sera mise en service en
octobre dans la ville de tours jacques
violer ce minibus avec sa petite
remorque utilisent pour rouler
indifféremment deux modes de propulsion
l'électricité ou le gasoil mais pourquoi
deux systèmes sur un même véhicule
pourquoi pas seulement l'électricité
si l'on savait faire une propulsion
électrique parfaite qu'ils fassent de
très grandes distances
il y aurait évidemment plus que ça
pratiquement ses gros avantage c'est
gros avantage de bruit de pollution
d'agrément on en a absolument besoin
dans les centres villes historiques mais
pas obligatoirement en campagne et où
ils d'électricité pour toujours le
problème de la recharge des batteries
sur ce véhicule une autonomie d'une
cinquantaine de kilomètres
alors l'idée d'y associer le gasoil en
ville sur des trajets courts le véhicule
fonctionne avec l'électricité et la
remorque contient les batteries qui est
motrice et cette remorque qui pousse le
véhicule sur des trajets plus longs
jusqu'au dépôt véhicule peut fonctionner
au gasoil le changement de mode de
propulsion se fait instantanément par le
chauffeur lui-même sans quitter son
siège regarder et surtout écouter la
manoeuvre le passage de l'électricité au
diesel
les avantages quant au bruit sont
évidents la remorque avec les batteries
peut aussi très facilement être détaché
le véhicule devient alors un véhicule
traditionnel pour des transports sur des
trajets plus longs
dernier avantage en propulsion
électrique véhicule récupère une partie
de l'énergie au freinage
ce dernier né de l'industrie automobile
française est sortie des bureaux
d'études du nouveau groupe peugeot
talbot citroën les motards eux ne se
sont pas beaucoup préoccuper de la
prochaine baisse de l'essence
aujourd'hui il avait à faire valoir
beaucoup de sujets de mécontentement ils
l'ont fait s'est bruyamment mais sans
heurts à paris et dans une quarantaine
de villes de province
lorraine puis il y a quelques années
monsieur sécurité routière christian
gérondeau institué trois permis moto à
difficultés renforcées en fonction de
l'âge du motocycliste et de la cylindrée
du véhicule
l'émeute a souhaité qu'il n'y ait plus
que de permis plus facile à obtenir
en raison du coup il y a trois semaines
un conseil interministériel se réunisse
la réglementation n'est guère changé de
monde c'est parce que c'est un secret de
polichinelle que les permis qui ont été
mis en place sont des permis mercantile
qui ont été faits pour favoriser une
industrie au détriment de la sécurité et
que les jeunes actuellement sont
limitées sur les 80 cm qui sont encore
plus dangereux que les 125 alors le
couvercle le gouvernement d'aujourd'hui
qui dans l'opposition hier que la nes et
père me disait que c'étaient les mesures
discriminatoires envers les jeunes s'est
plaint me sens toujours en place
qu'est ce que fait le gouvernement on en
a marre il faut que on a un gouvernement
de gauche il faut qui s'il est prêt de
la jeunesse si les prêts des engagements
qui devait prendre
il doit les respecter et c'est pour nous
racontant la messe avant les élections
qu'on changera le problème
selon les mots de par les règles du
permis et les normes d'homologation des
véhicules en france sont surtout inspiré
par le souci de limiter les importations
japonaises veine précaution puisque
l'industrie de la moto française est
presque inexistante et non compétitive
autre sujet de mécontentement
l'augmentation cette année de 20% des
assurances qui porte la prime annuelle à
9000 francs et plus enfin dernière
revendication les chaussées les bandes
blanches et les pavés notamment sont des
pièges à me pas autre manifestation cet
après midi à paris plus silencieuse
celle du front national et du parti des
forces nouvelles qui place de l'étoile
entendaient protester contre le
terrorisme à la suite de l'assassinât
d'un légionnaire en corse jean marie le
pen le président du front national a
déposé une gerbe devant la tombe du
soldat inconnu
les manifestants demandaient également
qu'on ne touche pas à l'intégrité du
territoire français
l'agent stade de son côté a évoqué les
récentes opérations du parti des forces
nouvelles contre deux ministères
l'extrême droite relève la tête en
france dit l'agent officiel soviétique
enfin cette intervention de michel debré
ce matin dans le figaro
nous sommes entrés dans une ère
d'arbitraire qui nuit à l'état et à la
liberté
à l'étranger tout d'abord la dévaluation
du franc belge bruxelles en effet décidé
de négocier avec ses partenaires de la
cee un réajustement de la parité du
franc belge au sein du système monétaire
européen réajustement on sait ce que ça
veut dire
une dévaluation sans doute de l'ordre de
10% environ
et puis en espagne un discours attendu
du roi aujourd'hui à saragosse
l'occasion était le 100e anniversaire de
la création de l'académie militaire mais
au lendemain du procès des putschistes
d'il ya un an cette adresse à l'armée
prenait un sens très particulier
nous sommes à saragosse et ce matin juan
carlos venait assister au centième
anniversaire de l'école militaire dont
il a été l'élève pendant une dizaine
d'années cette armée espagnole la voici
aujourd'hui et depuis la mort de franco
le roi d'espagne et le chef suprême de
l'armée
ces militaires aux sentiments ambigus
aussi bien vis-à-vis de la constitution
que de la couronne en fait les
militaires espagnoles n'arrivent
toujours pas à s'adapter au changement
de régime après quarante années de
dictature
un malaise profond car paradoxalement
c'est son chef
juan carlos qui essaie de conduire le
pays vers un régime totalement
démocratique
après une messe qui précède tout acte
officiel dans cette espagne profondément
catholique
le roi juan carlos va prononcer un grand
discours militaire et politique
et bien sûr ce n'est pas une coïncidence
24 heures seulement après l'ouverture du
procès des putschistes du 23 février
hier à madrid
bien sûr dans ce discours pas d'allusion
directe au procès mais juan carlos a
demandé à ses pairs de respecter la
démocratie la loi toute la loi espagnole
depuis un an en effet beaucoup
d'officiers complotent on a même assisté
à des mouvements d'un discipline dans
les casernes et de nombreux militaires
se sont solidarisés avec les putschistes
du 23 février
et puis comment ne pas se poser de
questions devant cette armée
omniprésente dont les services secrets
ou n'ont pas pu ou voulu avertir le
gouvernement et le roi des complots qui
se trament est cependant ces militaires
devraient être assurés les actes de
terrorisme ont diminué le processus
d'autonomie des provinces a été freinée
et le climat social s'est très nettement
apaisées pourtant ces officiers ses
généraux pratiquement tous élevés dans
le culte du franquisme
reste encore le principal danger qui
menace la démocratie espagnole
ici à saragosse juan carlos est venu
leur demander fidélité et loyauté une
nouvelle fois mais la situation est
bloquée car le roi a pris conscience
qu'il ne peut rien faire sans ces
militaires mais aussi qu'il ne peut rien
faire avec eux
irlande des élections générales n'ont
pas permis une fois de plus de dégager
une majorité absolue au parlement c'est
le parti d'opposition qui arrive en tête
liban les combats sont poursuivies à
tripoli dans le nord du pays le cessez
le feu n'a pas été respecté des deux
côtés l'union soviétique et bien
l'accident du métro de moscou aurait
fait 15 à 30 morts et plusieurs
centaines de blessés dit le journaliste
soviétique victor-louis toujours très
bien informé
enfin en tunisie fin de la visite
officielle de pierre mauroy qui restait
là bas quand même jusqu'à demain soir
pour un séjour privé dans une oasis du
sud tunisien est en nous maintenant sur
une polémique qui divise les américains
oui ou non les militaires qui
stationnaient loin des centres
nucléaires en atmosphère ont-ils été
contaminés voilà longtemps qu'on ne
procède plus à pareille explosion depuis
presque vingt ans aussi bien d'ailleurs
aux états unis qu en urss mais ces
militaires commencent à se plaindre pour
eux mêmes et pour leurs enfants ne
trouble qui pourrait bien n'avoir été
provoquée par des radiations de 1945 on
dit
70 les etats unis ont procédé à 212
expériences atomiques à les relie au
nevada sur le sol américain ou dans des
îlots du pacifique
à chaque fois des militaires américains
sont trouvés à proximité de la zone
d'expérimentation soit par kt et
nécessaire au déroulement de
l'expérience soit pour tester le
comportement des troupes à proximité
d'une zone d'explosion dans tous les cas
les experts et des médecins militaires
étaient formels toutes les précautions
avaient été prises
aucun des militaires n'avait pu être
exposés à une dose dangereuse de
radiation et pourtant depuis quelques
semaines un mouvement s'amplifie parmi
des vétérans des anciens de l'armée
américaine certains d'entre eux
affirment avoir subi des dommages
physiques souffert de maladies donner le
jour à des enfants anormaux et tout cela
distille en raison des radiations qu'ils
ont subies au cours de ces expériences
ces affirmations ne sont pas nouvelles
déjà sur 15 cents plaintes 14 anciens
militaires ont obtenu que des tribunaux
civils jeudi biens civils des
reconnaissent victimes d'irradiation
dangereuse pour leur vie ou leur santé
des vétérans se sont regroupés dans une
association
il y a quelques jours les déclarations
d'un ancien médecin militaire ont fait
scandale
il y avait deux livres la de ses livres
étaient le livre sérieux celui sur
lequel on écrivait la vérité quelle
qu'elle soit sur le volume des
radiations
l'autre livre est à relever journaliers
pour chaque soldat qui était fait de
manière à montrer chaque jour un taux de
radiation inférieur au maximum tolérable
ils m'ont fait signe un papier disant
que ces doubles relevées n'avaient
jamais
ce papier je l'ait signé devant des
responsables et ils m'ont dit que si
jamais je révélais c'est fait je
pourrais être inculpé de haute trahison
jugé pour haute trahison en ne
présentant qu'un sommet sur ce que what
mais s'il le france ils vont jusqu'au
bout ils devront ouvrir ces maudits
livres pour l'instant le pentagone
ministère américain de la défense les
autorités militaires se taisent mais les
anciens soldats qui s'estime victime
expériences nucléaires ils sont plus de
15 cents paraissent bien décidés à se
faire entendre
il sera donc difficile pour les
militaires de se taire encore longtemps
la pharmacienne de marne et en
haute-saône qui a toujours refusé
délivrer des contraceptifs et qui était
cité aujourd'hui pour refus de vente a
été relaxé par la cour d'appel le lion
une dizaine de policiers blessés la nuit
dernière salle wagram à paris lors
d'incidents entre brésiliens qui fêtait
le carnaval avec un petit peu trop d'
enthousiasme et puis à ce stade du
journal une étape lilloise lille qui
vient de se doter d'un théâtre national
de région le troisième du genre après
marseille et lyon avec pour la semaine
prochaine à un spectacle tout à fait
intéressant l'interpréter c'est vraiment
le cas de le dire dans une langue très
particulière le sa période à reportage
de yoga grégoire leur envie de lui qu'à
yale déglingué chambry pneus si je ne me
retenais c'est vrai qu'elle est venue si
mou sur bondy net et tout est comme
alors alors vide au pilote situant aux
ben quoi tu t'es broche jugé la simone
damman brusquer ce n'est pas un nouveau
ch'timi que l'on parle à lille mais
l'aca peyrelongue inventé par gildas
bourdet directeur du nouveau théâtre de
région installé dans une ancienne salle
de boxe en attendant les aménagements on
y implanter une ministre
à l'envers doux de la rue on voit
évoluer les acteurs un choix pour
l'auteur d'ouvrir le très institutionnel
théâtre national sur un vaudeville à
trois personnages un homme pour deux
femmes se conventionnelle trio n'aurait
aucune saveur s'il ne parlait dans une
langue ignoré des dictionnaires sans que
je ne m'en rende compte
les mots ont commencé à ce chant boulet
a de façon à produire quelque chose de
plus sensuelle que ce que permet la
langue française usuelles alors au bout
d'un moment je m'en suis aperçu j'ai eu
peur de tomber dans un système lors j'ai
essayé d'éviter tout système à
l'intérieur de l'écriture mais ça ne
correspond pas un projet de départ que
j'aurai réalisé c'est venu malgré moi
pas rancunier plat la brèche en soi de
land'art deux chais pas dans l'intention
de sant pere latence et jusqu'à perdre
outre non mais de vraies c'est déroutant
mais c'est très très jubilatoire quand
on se bat constamment fin a aucun
problème
on comprend tout ou à peu près quand on
comprend pas la parole on comprend les
gestes
ça change et des spectacles disons que
les solutionner je comprends ce fut très
bien l'histoire et qui a un plaisir qui
est accrue si vous voulez du fait que
c'est pas langage habituel quand on sait
qu'ici les gens qui parlent le ch'timi
il ya des gens qui parlent le flamand
il ya des gens qui parlent de ce que
j'appelle le renault ou c'est une sorte
de verlan et ces gens là on apprend le
français et au dos alors ça a du mal à
rentrer et le sapeur l'eau c'est comme
vincent très nettement c'est comme une
espèce de jubilation de revanche c'est à
dire qu'ils viennent dans une
institution culturelle et on leur dit
bien non le français finalement c'est
parce que c'est ou peut-être c'est ça
pourrait être autre chose alors je crois
que ça déclenche des réactions très très
saine au contraire sa paire langues
argo borborygmes de bande dessinée a
fait école même si de loin ou de près on
la compare à de l'alfred jarry nom du
jean tardieu et linguiste ainsi que des
littéraires de l'université de lille se
sont penchés sur le phénomène et vont
organiser des débats drilles ont essayé
de penser avec la troupe de gildas
bourdet
c'est ce qu'ils s'engagent sous le rire
même qu'est ce qui se passe quand on
joue avec la langue et où va-t-on quand
on joue avec la langue
je suis la vie nouvelle et mobilisera
deux sites riquier dopantes a jeté sur
une claquette de la fonderie den que tu
enfiles jamais caché ni bros le chantre
barnave en fermant les milliers
voilà six un test et parisiens sachez
que le super lot viendra à paris au
festival d'automne le tiercé maintenant
vincennes c'est fini demain la reprise
des beaux dimanches d'auteuil calebasse
exactement après les brillantes
démonstrations des trotteurs aux allures
très technique vieux j'aime bien la
réouverture des courses plates avec les
galopeurs il faut dire qu'avec auteuil
et les courses d'obstacles et bien les
performances sportives de ses shows et
de ces jockeys aux photos spectacle
vraiment très beau très fort demain par
exemple le tiercé va se courir dans le
prix de clermont-tonnerre c'est une
course de ce type de chaises longues de
4100 mètres
cela veut dire que les dix-neuf
concurrents engagés dans cette course
bien non seulement devons être doué mais
aussi être mécanisée avoir du métier
pour se tait les 10 obstacles de ce type
qui offre autant de difficultés que deux
grosses heures les uns que les autres
voilà igas riga ce que je vous présente
maintenant n'a que 6 ans mais après nous
fait carrière sur les ses débuts
victorieux sur le steeple annonce déjà
comme un futur crack dans cette
spécialité avec rigal vous tenez un
super cheval pour hôtels sur le stick en
ce moment pour le moment ça a l'air de
bien se passer et il a débuté en fin
d'année où il a gagné très facilement et
après une deuxième course en ce type il
a également gagné très facilement
il reste donc sur deux victoires à
auteuil mais il ya eu tout l'hiver entre
temps et comment se retrouve t elle à la
rentrée là il a très bien hiverné il a
il est sorti tout l'hiver sans problème
et je crois même qu'il a fait des
progrès après depuis qu'on leur travail
là et il me semble en progression il
aura besoin d'une concentré où ça peut
marcher d'emblée comme ça je pense que
dans belle doit pas le gêner à ça doit
ça doit pouvoir être à sa portée
bien entendu il ya des chocs et de
qualité dans la course qui n'avait pas
rencontré jusque là mais il a la classe
ans et c'est un des meilleurs shows de
et donc sautant bien devrait pas y avoir
de problème riga ce que vous venez de
voir sera mon favori ensuite fine peau
est une jument qui a déjà fait preuve de
beaucoup de talent sur les gros
obstacles découpe les nuages de les
entraîner tous deux par jacques hubert
barre de son des valeurs
dans ce cas c'est bon absolument
mon doudou est encore jeune mais il est
paraît-il en gros progrès tout comme
mass idéaux qui est à lui aussi cinq ans
de la mort et petits thoune et
termineront ce choix là ils porteront la
numéro 8 6 4 1 11 19 16 et 14 tours
progrès alors mon cher laurent broomhead
vous avez des choses à nous dire pour la
météo qui peuvent concerner des routes
assez auteuil extrême complexité
ce samedi parce qu'aussi de la france
s'affrontent deux masses d'air très
différent d'une part du côté de l'est
vient de l'air froid et de l'autre côté
de l'air doux de l'atlantique
le résultat d'une carte pour le moins
compliquée un petit peu le froid d'abord
ensuite le redoux on va voir ça avec
précision ici et en d'étals d'abord une
grande bande de nuages ici à celle très
nuageux à couvert avec quelques averses
de neige parfois depuis mais surtout de
petits flocons de neige ça c'est la
carte du matin voyez ici depuis la
normandie bassin parisien pays de loire
massif central jusqu'aux languedoc et
jusqu'à la corse
plus on en reste dès demain matin en
froid avec des gelées et puis tout de
même du soleil assez beau avec
simplement quelques nuages
de l'autre côté du côté de la bretagne
tentent souvent très gris et brumeux
avec des brouillards même localement ça
c'est le matin dans la journée ce temps
là va avoir tendance à se déplacer
légèrement vers le sud-ouest permettant
de plus belles éclaircies dans le
nord-est mais regardez de l'autre côté
ici l'arrivée de nouvelles pluies
précédé de neige à la rencontre de l'air
froid
ces nuages où ont pénétré et
progressivement en veillant la bretagne
puis la normandie les pays de loire et
l'ouest du massif central donc
globalement si vous voulez pour
simplifier pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
tout suivi et bien sur la moitié ouest
du pays beaucoup de nuages un temps
humide et plus doux et un temps plus
froid et plus ensoleillé dans la moitié
est voilà les températures par donc je
reste là vous m'excusez c'est pas encore
la vie si on garde cette liste on va
montrer la liste c'est température ici à
vous voyez une france coupée en deux
nord-est au-dessus de 5 en dessous de 5
degrés est et sud ouest ou en dessus
avec un temps doux contre un temps froid
voilà maintenant je vais revenir dans
mon petit carré pour vous donner
l'agenda quand vous consultez cet agenda
je vous dirais que lundi bien sûr le
doubs qui l'emportera avec a traversé le
nuage d'ouest en est suivie d'un temps
variable patrick merci alors ça veut
dire donc un terrain lourd demain à
auteuil pas que c'est pas bon pour mon
doudou le dernier journal vous sera
présenté à 23h15 par jacques merino il
développera les titres dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure c'est à dire la
défaite du quinze de france devant
l'angleterre 27 15 au parc des princes
les sens en baisse le mois prochain sans
doute 10 centimes de moins nous a dit
laurence graff 1 et puis en marge du
procès des putschistes en espagne un
appel du roi à l'armée voilà pour ma
part j'aurais pu vous retrouver demain
soir à 20 heures
bonne soirée à tous